Turning now to tragedy this evening
at a Florida hospital.
A 76 year
old woman is in custody
after allegedly shooting and killing
her terminally ill husband.
She then apparently barricaded herself
in his hospital room,
forcing officials
to evacuate
staff and patients
and declare a lockdown.
No one else was threatened or injured.
Daytona Beach
police said an investigation determined
the couple planned this weeks ago.
Apparently because he was terminally ill.
They had a conversation about it
and they actually planned this
approximately three weeks ago,
that if he continued to take a turn
for the worse that she wanted,
he wanted her to end this.
Initially,
I think the plan was a murder suicide.
So she killed him
and then she was going
to turn the gun on herself,
but decided she
couldn't go through with it.
And we
were told the woman's
husband was 77 years old.
She could be facing a first degree
murder charge.
CNN national security
analyst Juliette Kayyem joins us.
Juliette,
this is such a sad story
for so many reasons, right
Have you ever heard of a murder suicide
inside a hospital?
Obviously,
she didn't follow
through on the suicide part.
That was part of the plan.
I mean,
would it be relatively easy
at most hospitals
to get a gun into someone's room?
Yes.
And I mean, part of this is not.
No matter
how strong security measures are
and they're certainly worth looking at
you can't sort of sort of plan
for every scenario, including this one,
which is just you know,
it's just tragic any way you look at it.
I'm not defending any of the decisions
this couple
decides that they want to go together,
so to speak,
and she can't follow through and
and barricades herself.
The challenge at a hospital is family
members are treated
as sort of trusted visitors
as they should be, especially if ever.
If a spouse is terminally ill,
spouses will come in and out
that a lot of them will get badged.
Any parent
listening knows that
when your children come visit it
or have to be in hospitals,
that's the same thing.
And so there are sort of their insiders.
And so you're sort of not expecting this
at this stage.
My assumption
is that they don't have metal detectors,
at least
that all the doors at the hospital
they may want to check in to this,
but this is rare murder-suicide.
I tend to be either quite violent, right?
A man
killing his wife and then himself
or tend to be quite private.
And this is this is just unique
and hopefully, you know, as that the wife
charging her with first degree murder
will probably be taken
into account in terms of,
of course,
the circumstances of the decision
that that couple made. Right.
The agreement that police said that
the husband had asked her,
according to police, to kill him
if his condition got worse,
he was terminally ill.
How do police
deal with this type of situation?
I mean,
they were able
to get the woman to surrender.
So at some stage when they know
it's not a true active shooter,
like the kinds that you and
I think
about her off
and on about in terms of someone
just basically wants the body count.
Right.
That this is
this is a situation in which it was quite
planned and and targeted.
And their only concern is
if there were other patients
in that room which
which it appears that there weren't
and then,
of course, the patients that are around
that room and protecting them.
So they're going to treat this
and did treat this as a as a more typical
rather than active shooter.
As a hostage situation.
There was no reason to believe
she was after anyone else.
They probably likely knew her
because he had been in the hospital
at least a couple of weeks.
And so they're able to bring her out
without further harm to herself
and then to get the care that she needs.
You know,
we sometimes think of these cases,
you know,
in the sort of safety security lens
and why how could this happen?
And sometimes there are situations
in which
you really
can't sort of plan for
because they're so unique and maybe
just just different and kind,
which this one is
and one in which
I think the authorities are
are really going to have to think about
whether first degree murder is
is the appropriate charge
given the circumstances
and context that we know.
Joining us now is Dr.
Joshua Hornstein.
He's a cardiologist
who had a shelter in place
at ADVENTHEALTH Hospital in Daytona Beach
while all of this was unfolding.
Dr.
Hornstein, thank you for being with us.
No doubt
this had to be a frightening moment
for you other staffers.
Can you walk us through what happened?
Certainly.
Thanks for having me.
First, I just have to say
how appreciative
I am of all the law enforcement
who were there, how quickly they acted
and how they were able
to resolve the situation
about their loss of life.
Well,
it it was
it was pretty scary,
especially in the early part of it.
We just had no idea what was going on.
I was around in the emergency department
when a
announcement came
by the overhead speakers saying
yellow and we get colds all the time.
That referred to,
you know, patients
having cardiac distress.
But yellow is not something
you need to have ever heard before.
So people are looking on their badges
to see what that even means.
And it says lockdown so well, again,
looking at each other
like lockdown to do about that.
And then another 10 seconds later,
another alarm goes off
saying cold shoulder shelter in place.
And that's where pandemonium started.
But in a controlled pandemonium,
everyone started
getting all the patients
behind their closed doors
and a nurse
who had to get into the supply closet.
So she and I went in there
and we basically just sat there
for the next 30, 40 minutes
until we started
getting some information
out to Twitter about what was going on.
Dr..
Yeah, we were just showing the video
a few moments ago.
We showed again of the video
I think you took inside that supply room.
Yes.
I mean,
what was going through your mind
when you were waiting in there?
So for the first few seconds,
like this is just like any other fire.
All been through my whole life.
It's not it's not real.
But there were a couple of moments
when you would hear
door slamming and raised voices,
and it's hard not to flash back any video
of any mass shooting at all
seen over these years.
And suddenly it is real.
And you don't know that it's an old lady
on the top floor.
You just thought, you know,
there's a shooter outside the room.
If you saw the picture of the
stretcher barricading the door
and, you know,
you're looking at that saying
is only going to stop the shooter
if they want to get in here?
That's what's going through your mind.
Yeah. And Dr.
I mean, your reaction to the fact
that somebody was able to
I mean, obviously,
this was a tragic situation
where this woman
and her husband apparently
took it upon themselves
to do this sort of thing.
But your reaction to somebody
being able to bring a gun into a hospital
like that?
It's terrible.
You know,
this isn't even the first time
in my career
this has happened
when I was in training in San Diego,
murder suicide
almost exactly like this of patients
who were a patient
who was terminally ill.
And, you know, it
speaks a lot for gun
violence in the country.
Even though they had this pact.
Is this going the way to do it?
It was so violent
and and and so distress and distress,
sort of not
not just the staff,
but all the patients that are there
trying to recover and healing
what's going on. I mean, it was dreadful.
And did you talk to other
folks there
in the hospital who heard the shot?
No, I was on the ground floor
in the emergency department,
just as it turned out.
Happened on the 11th floor, I believe.
So we were
drastically far removed from it.
That's good.
And what kind of resources
are being provided to staffers there?
I'm guessing that the hospital
is trying to deal with the situation
right now.
Yeah, and I have
the police left the area.
Yeah.
I imagine
that'll become more clear
over the next day. Or two.
The first step is basically trying
to return the hospital
to some sense of normal operations
because there's still hundreds
of patients to receive care.
If we can't get to the floors,
we need to get to
because police
had to do their safety sweeps.
So patient care trumps everything.
And then following that,
I know the hospital will be working
with any staff in there,
you know, understandable to stress.
And what goes through your mind, Doctor,
thinking about,
you know, the awful situation
that so many families find themselves in
where a loved one is terminally ill,
going through a very difficult
experience of passing
and they're
tempted to do something like this.
Yeah.
You know, I've come to my job.
I think people on stage are still here.
You know, on a very routine basis.
To me,
it seems like
there are so many options out there.
You know,
hospital is an amazing resource
to patients
who are terminally ill where they can,
you know, be pain free and anxiety free.
And it's really,
you know, a great program.
I don't know how someone can
get to the desperate
desperation level
to take on such an extreme measure.
But there really are resources out there.